hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and today
we're gonna talk about a topic that no
one has ever really disagreed about
before which is the relationship of
science and religion actually I'm just
kidding just have to say that cuz it's
the Internet right that's the sarcasm
people have disagreed about this before
in fact people have very strong opinions
about it so I'm sure the people who
listened to the episode will bring those
opinions to the experience the person
I'm talking to is Alan Lightman who's a
professor of writing at MIT
Alan is sort of uniquely positioned to
think about these kinds of issues
because he was a successful professional
physicist who transitioned into being a
successful writer and professor of
writing you may know him from the very
famous and celebrated book Einsteins
Dreams which was a novel in the form of
a number of different scenarios that
Albert Einstein might have been thinking
about when he was inventing the theory
of relativity so he's really a
successful example of someone who has
mastered both Sciences and the
humanities and actually in this
discussion I think it's safe to say we
don't disagree that much there's little
tiny differences of emphasis here and
there but we're both naturalist we're
both atheists and we want to be firm
about that but also to carve out some
space for talking about experiences
where you might feel connected to the
universe experiences of transcendence
and meaningfulness and so forth without
saying that these are evidence of
anything supernatural whatsoever
but how should we think about these what
should we say about them how can we talk
about them and also how should we talk
to people who have different points of
view than we do about the existence of
supernatural stuff whether it's God or
spirits or anything else I think both
Allen and I are generally pretty you
know polite conciliatory kind of people
we want everyone just to get along and
there's lots of atheists out there who
are not of that cast of mind so I tried
my best to find some little areas of
disagreement here and there but most
mostly we agree I think that everyone
including myself will disagree a little
bit even with things I said because my
mind changes about this but it's a great
starting point for thinking carefully
about how to be
secular atheist scientific in a world
where most people are still believing in
other things so it's a great
conversation I hope you enjoy it let me
also say as usual you're welcome to go
to the website preposterous universe
calm slash podcast and support mindscape
through patreon for recurring donations
or PayPal for one in time donations I
should say by the way for the paypal
donators for people who have donated
money over paypal i don't have any easy
way to thank you on patreon you know we
have the ask me anything every month if
you're a patreon supporter and I can you
know say thanks there in the comments
and so forth so just let me say right
here let me take this opportunity to
give my great appreciation for everyone
who has supported the podcast over
PayPal I really do appreciate it helps
keep the podcast going helps keeping me
energized and with that let's go
[Music]
allan lichtman welcome to the mindscape
podcast nice to be with you Sean so I
like to have a variety of guests on the
podcast and I'm a physicist so of course
there's perhaps an overabundance of
physicists represented compared to the
average intellectual landscape but
you're a physicist but who has a an
interesting career tell us about how you
started as a physicist and you've moved
into other things well I was interested
in both the sciences and the arts from a
young age on the science side I did
homemade science projects I built
rockets and remote control devices and
things that a lot of budding scientists
do I also like to write poetry and short
stories and read a lot and so I sort of
had this dual interest in the sciences
and the arts from a young age I didn't
have any too many role models of people
who became both scientists and writers i
but I did realize that I should get
myself well grounded as a scientist
first before I get began forays into the
netherworld of the horse I I knew a few
scientists who had later life became
writers like CP snow but I didn't know
if any writers who in later life became
scientists so he subsequently learned of
any I have not learned of any yet if you
know anything let me know little
challenge for the young people out there
right so it appears that science is a
young person's game especially in
physics the greatest accomplishments in
physics had been done done by people who
are younger so I decided that I would
get myself well established and
enrolling in physics first so I got my
undergraduate and graduate degrees in
physics but I continued writing sort of
on the weekends and hobbies
weekends and evenings and then I would
say around in my early 30s or mid 30s
I began spending more time with my
writing and by the time I was 40 my
research career in physics was was
beginning to slow down a bit and I began
putting more time into my writing I had
been on the Faculty of Harvard and then
at some point I moved to the Faculty of
MIT were actually had a joint
professorship in both the sciences and
the humanities or the arts which is a
weird thing how did you ever convince
them to even offer you such a thing any
other universities are a little bit
sticky about the same procedure well I
talked to people both in the physics
department and in the writing department
at that time it was part of the
humanities department at MIT and I don't
know how I convinced them I guess I must
I must have hoodwinked them in some
fashion but I had a little bit to show
for myself and suppose the physicist and
a writer at that point this would have
been around 1988 about 30 years ago and
I was very fortunate that they were
willing to consider this odd appointment
and I think it's safe to say that your
breakthrough was the novel Einstein's
dreams which remains you know a really
remarkable accomplishment in many ways
tell us just a very little bit about
what that book is and how in the world
you came to have that concept for a
novel
well the novel is a bunch of short
vignettes and each one is a fictional
dream that Einstein might have had as he
was working as a way towards his theory
of relativity which is a theory of
time and in each chapter
Einstein sort of tries on a different
version of time and when world time
moves backwards in another one it moves
in a circle and another people can't
remember their past as some of them are
more physical and some are more
psychological I think the the idea
occurred to me
partly because I've always been
interested in the tension between our
scientific side and our artistic side
and that sort of represented by Einstein
as the representing that the scientific
rational side and our dreams
representing are more intuitive artistic
side that was sort of the theme I have
always loved the magic realist writers
like Bohr Hayes and Gabriel Garcia
Marquez and Italo Calvino sure and and
those writers were I think influential
on me it's with her was there ever a
time in the conception of that book when
you thought it was going to be a
nonfiction book more straightforward it
was always going to be a fiction book
and and not only that but as I conceived
of each one of the thirty dream worlds
in the book corresponds to the actual
theory of relativity yeah and all the
other ones are totally made-up and do
not correspond to physical reality
reality at all but when I was conceiving
and writing each of the dream worlds
there was a temptation to try to make it
scientifically plausible and I resisted
that temptation yeah because I thought
it would weigh down the book right and
were you I mean this is a you you're
welcome not to answer this question but
while you were writing it were you
thinking to yourself you know boy I got
something good on my hands here or were
you like oh my god people are gonna
think I'm crazy no I didn't think of any
of those things
when I went when I began running the
Berk book it was like I went into a
dream myself it was an incredible
credibly intense experience where for
the first three or four months I was
just living in this book and it was like
one intense rush of adrenaline that
lasted three months and I wasn't
thinking about anything regarding myself
or whether I had a good idea or what the
reception of the book would be I was
just in this this dreamscape this this
creative space I guess some people call
it this zone or whatever and so I was
not thinking about anything outside of
this imaginary world that I was in but
it's a wonderful example of the sort of
interaction between science and the
humanities because whether or not you
wanted to make each one of those worlds
physically plausible there's certainly a
very close similarity to the invention
of those worlds and what a real
theoretical physicist does right you
know trying to invent a system mm-hmm
right that's true and sometimes I wonder
whether a non physicist could have
written that book and I think maybe so
but I do think that that some of the
ways that I thought about time or at
least how to construct it we're
certainly aided by my background in
physics of course each each of those
dream worlds you have to match an idea
conception of time with with a human
story that illustrates that idea and
this is a great segue actually because
this idea of being in the zone of sort
of you know losing yourself feeds
directly into your most recent book
which I'm not gonna get the title
exactly right sorry you don't have it in
front of me you must know the title
right searching for stars on an island
in Maine there you go
and you tackle subject no one has ever
written about before really which is the
relationship between science and
religion and spirituality so why would I
imagine
imagine that some people have written
about it before yeah no I'm just kidding
about that it's it's it seems to be
something that a lot of people are very
interested in everyone has their own
little take well and I think you know
just to warn both you and me and the
audience probably you and I agree on
many of the issues here and yet I
suspect that our conversation is going
to feature a bit of the narcissism of
small differences because the small
differences matter in something like
this right is this is material that is
very very important and and subtle and
hard so it's okay to get into the weeds
about what you said is not even wrong
certainly and I wouldn't expect us to
agree completely on everything so what
was the inspiration for writing this
book I've always been interested in the
dialog between science and religion and
I think that those two institutions are
the the most powerful forces the two
most powerful forces in the development
of our civilization and I always wanted
to write a book that was located in this
island that I spend my wife and I spend
every summer on for the last thirty
years so I sort of combined the two I
did not want to confront the subject of
science and religion head-on as you've
said there have been many many people
have written on it and scholars who know
much more than I do
so I wanted to take a more tangential
approach and I wrote the book sort of
like an extended meditation as I'm
wondering about this island in Maine you
had this wonderful very specific story
that I'm sure you told many times but
let's tell it for the listeners they
might not know it about being right off
that Island in your boat and feeling
something yes I was coming back to the
island one night in my boat and
everybody who lives in the island all
the families have their own boat because
it's it's a remote island and it's not
connected by bridges or ferries it's
coming back to the island in my boat
when night after midnight was very quiet
and it was a dark sky and I decided that
would turn off the engine of the boat
and it got even quieter and then I
turned off the running lights and a got
even darker and I lay down in the boat
and just looked up at the sky and with
all us this wonderful sharp stars up
there and I felt like I was falling into
infinity I felt like I lost all sense of
my body or a time or space and I was
just part of the cosmos I felt a
connection to something much larger than
myself and I felt that the the infinite
expanse of time before I was born and
the the infinite expanse of time after I
will be dead all of that seemed
compressed to a dot it was a totally
amazing experience and I'm sure that you
and other people have had experiences
like that and yet coming out of that
experience you maintained firmly
convinced in your materialist view of
the world why you'd not leap from this
experience to the existence of something
outside the natural world but you wanted
to try to understand how we reconcile
naturalism physicalism material
experiences of this sort so how do we do
that
what is your what is your what lesson do
you draw on I the experience that I had
was was something that I that I called
the transcendent experience and I know
other people have used that word
terminology as well and for me the
transcendent experience in a nutshell is
feeling that you are connected to
something larger than yourself that
there's some order in the universe and
the transcendent experience that does
not need to involve God and in fact I am
pretty close to an atheist myself as I
imagine that you are as well and but I
think there are still something very
powerful about that experience and
something that cannot be studied
quantitatively it's not reduce
the ball by the usual usual methods of
science that is I think if you had
connected every neuron of my brain to a
giant computer during that period of
time where I was lying down in the boat
looking up at the stars if you had the
electrical readout of every neuron in my
brain I think you still it still would
not have have qualitative lien they
conveyed the the experience that I had
and I think those sorts of experiences
to me represent the spiritual world and
I believe that we that all of us have
had experiences like that and we need to
recognize them there they're not easily
analyzable by the methods of science but
it's another very very valid way of
being in the world and I think that it's
part of this very very long history of
of people human beings connecting with
the cosmos I think you can see it and
the cave the cro-magnon cave paintings
in France and you can hear it in and
Beethoven's Ninth Symphony it's it's
it's an emotional connection to the
cosmos so the recognition of those kinds
of experiences and the the honouring of
them and acceptance of them which may or
may not involve a belief in God is the
way that I think that spirituality and
science are reconciled yeah I think that
you know one of the issues that one
always faces here is the fact that just
like in doing science we talk about
these concepts using vocabulary that has
been I ended down for hundreds of years
and it's it's afraid with certain
connotations and so forth so there's
always and you know free will is another
area of debate where that comes in so in
particular you seem
to be willing to use the word
spirituality but at the same time you're
not actually saying you believe in
spirits right so what what convinces you
though it may not be the right
vocabulary and I don't want to get hung
up on on words I think that the
description of the experience that I had
in the boat lying up looking for the
Stars and I've had other experiences
like that and I imagine that that many
of you we your listeners have had
experiences like that that a description
of the experience itself and the
feelings that you have during such
experiences is much more accurate than
trying to sum up them up in a word like
spirituality so when I use a word like
that
and I'm aware that it has a lot of
freight with it as as does the word God
that that that the word does not contain
the experience so I'd rather talk about
the experience and and we can give it
when we you and I'll talk about it in
this conversation we can give at some
shorthand we could call it number 17 or
experiment number 18 or the letter gamma
we can we can refer to it in any way
that we want as long as we know what
we're referring to good let me give you
an example I mean sorry let me give you
an opportunity because you've written
this wonderful book full of specific
examples so rather than like you say
debating the word which I don't really
want to do either why don't you just
offer a couple more examples of what you
mean by this because I think that we are
talking about universal human
experiences but different people have
different examples they would turn to
when they talk about this kind of idea
you want me to give other examples and
them from the book or naughty or from
anyway just like you let's sort of
around the concept I mean you're falling
in love music looking at the stars art
you know like when you listen to a piece
of music that you were often carried
away to some kind of emotional space
that you can't describe certainly
falling in love is probably the most
mysterious interaction between two human
beings and I think it's it's really
unpredictable
whether to human beings are going to
fall in love with each other you can
look at their TVs ahead of time and that
was not going to tell you whether
they're they're attracted to each other
I can I can give one other illustration
of a specific thing that happened to me
if you want it'll take a couple of
minutes to describe well please and it
also happened on this island in Maine
but not all of my number-17 experiences
happen on this island but there's an
Ospreys nest about a hundred feet from
our house and every year for many years
for a couple of decades there was a
family of Ospreys that came every summer
and the parents would come in the
springtime and lay the eggs and then the
eggs would hatch around the beginning of
June and the babies would grow up over
the summer the the mother would stay on
the nest and the father would go out and
catch fish to feed the birds and my wife
and I used to watch this nest every
summer and and and observe the life
cycles of these birds and we got to know
them pretty well at least know that the
calls that they make and one summer I
had been watching these birds that I was
standing on a second floor deck of our
house and it's a circular deck and I was
looking at the nest and they were
looking at me and so the baby birds who
have been growing up over the summer
they don't take their first flight until
the end of the summer and they're just
growing bigger and bigger all over
through the summer and and even a baby
Osprey
a pretty big bird I don't know how many
of your your listeners are familiar with
Ospreys but they're the second biggest
bird after the eagle and they have a
giant a giant wingspan and they have
very powerful claws so I had been
looking at these these these off these
adolescent Ospreys over the summer and
they'd been looking back at me and to
them it must have looked like I was in
my nest because I once on this circular
depth there was about eye level with
their nest and finally the time came for
them to take their first flight and this
was the beginning of August and so that
we've been looking at each other all
summer long and they took their first
flight and the two adolescent birds who
were quite big by this time they did a
big loop like about a mile in diameter
and then they turned and they headed
straight for me as I stood on this
circular desk duck hitting for me at
great speed and their claws were out the
stem pre-trade sending to you sounds
like this anti transcendent so my first
instinct was to run back into the house
for cover because they easily could have
ripped my face off but something made me
hold my ground and I kept standing there
and the birds were coming towards me at
great speed and when they got about 20
feet away I mean they were so close I
could hear the wind moving around them
they suddenly did an upward acceleration
at about 3 G's and swooped and went over
the roof of the house but they had never
flown before they had another viewer
they know this brothers were about a
half a second or a second at most before
they did this 3G acceleration when they
were about 25
way they looked me straight in the eye
and I've never had any eye contact with
any animal with any human animal with my
wife that was equal to that it was about
a half of second a profound eye contact
and I felt in that half second that they
were talking to me and they were saying
we're brothers we share this land
together and we have shared this land
together and we're connected I felt and
we have decided not they did not run my
face off and I felt all of that conveyed
in that half second of my contact that
was a transcendent experience for me
yeah now this is very good I'm glad that
you did tell the story because it helps
to ground a little bit what we're
talking about and I think that other
people you know would have stories that
we can also relate to not I haven't had
anything just like what you described
but I think I get in when you describe
it right some other people might refer
to experiences on psychedelics or in
meditation or in a trance state and one
issue is some of these people who do
this the language that we use of being
connected to something else whether it's
something vast in cosmic or whether it's
another creature right in front of us is
that evidence for something I mean is it
evidence for something beyond the
natural and I think you want to say no
and is it evidence for something that is
still within the natural world and maybe
you want to say yes but then how do we
talk about what that trying well those
are very good questions and and I think
some people would say that that it is
evidence for something beyond the
natural world some people would say it's
evidence for you know a room we call me
Michael heaven some people might say
it's evidence for the existence of a
creator that some people might call God
for me it's evidence of Aniki
sensitivity of human beings for certain
kinds of emotional experiences and it's
it's it's it's related to the experience
I had lying on my back looking at the
stars in Maine it's related to looking
at at a Rembrandt painting or listening
to it Bach fugue I don't know what kind
of language we can use other than that
it is an acute sensitivity to certain
kinds of emotional experience it's it's
a receptivity you have to be receptive
you have to be open to experiences like
that and I think that's a key fact
there's there's a concept in Hinduism
which I'm trying to remember is
something like Dachau and I'm think I'm
mispronouncing it and what it means is
it's an openness to the sublime and the
sublime may or may not involve a deity
or not but it's the openness to these
kinds of experiences yeah I did he's
here my second podcast guest who's
talked about the sublime the first one
was going who is a design professor and
a musician at Stanford and you know both
in a perfectly secular context I like I
like the word sublime more than the word
spiritual because I mean it you know it
doesn't have quite as much baggage but
nevertheless I think that what's
important here is you're so we're both
on the same side in the sense that we
certainly agree there are experiences
like this we don't see any reason to
take them as evidence for something
supernatural in any right that's right
that's right I think that you made a
claim that it was a little provocative
and I want to dig into it about the idea
of opening up your brain and measuring
all your neurons and you want to claim
that such a extremely hypothetical
procedure would never reveal what's
going on in experiences like this is
that a fair way to say it
it would reveal what's going on at the
microscopic level I mean I think that it
would reveal all of the electrical
output of the neurons and and you can
measure that the chemical flows between
synapses I think it could reveal all of
that in tremendous quantitative detail
the question is after you had all of
that data would you be able to
understand the sensation that I felt and
it's as close to the same question as is
what is consciousness right the it's
very similar I mean because all of these
experiences are related to consciousness
and the experience of consciousness are
you familiar with the idea the concept
of supervenience have you heard your
philosopher friends talk about that
supervenience yes no I haven't heard
that before it's a way of talking about
this fuzzy area where something depends
on something but you can't necessarily
see it there
so something supervenes on something
else if the if there's a higher level
supervening on a lower level than right
that what that means is that if the
higher level were different it would
necessarily be the case that the lower
level would also have to be different
right the higher levels not just some
extra stuff all right
but derive ability is a much stronger
concept than simply supervenience so
right and it sounds similar to what the
the concept of emergent phenomena that
that's right but but emergence which I
love is as a phenomenon again has many
different sub versions right I've been
making a little bit more precise what's
going on okay all right but I think that
what you're getting at is very similar
to the thought experiment of Mary the
color scientist which I'm sure you do
know about the Frank Jackson had this
idea that we would raise this woman Mary
in a black and white room but we would
teach her everything there is to know
about color so she literally knows every
fact about photons and a human color
perception or whatever but she has never
seen anything red so the question is
when she leaves the room and sees red
does she learn something new and what he
said originally he later changed his
mind
but he originally said was that of
course she learns something new she
learns what it is like to experience the
color red and so and that's a very
Thomas Nagel kind of talk where there is
some separate category for what it is
like to experience something over and
above sort of the obvious sensory inputs
that we can easily figure out just by
looking at your neurons yeah yeah that
that all makes perfect sense to me
and of course the whole concept of
experiencing something is inseparable
from the experience of consciousness
right but I'm gonna push back a little
bit because is it are we giving up a
little bit too soon I mean is it just
that it's hard or it would be hard even
if we had the output of every single
neuron in your brain to the state of
every single neuron in your brain that
might be very very difficult to figure
out oh you know you're experiencing
something transcendent but maybe it's
just hard like you know if someone gave
you the ones and zeros in a JPEG file it
would be very difficult to look at a
string with ones and zeros and tell you
what was a picture of but it could be
done in principle so is it isn't that
kind of distinction well I I wouldn't I
would never say that it couldn't be done
in principle so it it may be that you
could look at the output of all of the
neurons the electrical output and you
could feed that output to another person
let's say you fed all the ones and zeros
to another person who was not in the
boat in Maine yeah but just plugged it
into their neural cortex it might be
that they could have exactly that
experience right I mean I I do think
that the world is ultimately all
material I am I am a materialist and
it's
you know it's it's a trick to reconcile
a hundred percent materiality with these
experiences that we have the experiences
are rooted in material things I mean
just like you know I think that there's
nothing in the brain except material
atoms and molecules I don't think
there's any magical essence but the
experience of consciousness which is
some higher level or what is that words
supervening yeah phenomena that
sensation that is brought about by all
of these electrical signals that that is
so hard to get our hands around and we
know that this is called the hard
problem in philosophy that it's very
difficult to say whether to what extent
we will eventually completely nail this
qualitative phenomenon yeah and I think
that there is the question as you allude
to of you know how far we will get in
the future but I think also this is
getting to the important part of the
discussion in the sense that there's
operationally a lesson to be learned now
in in your view from the fact that it's
very difficult right here and right now
to talk about the experience in a
realistic way so yes you you that would
go so far I think as to say that there
is a kind of knowledge or a kind of I'll
say knowledge you can correct me if
there's a better word kind of knowledge
we get from these that is in some sense
importantly different than the kind of
knowledge we get from science yes I
would say that and and I would be
surprised if you did not agree with me
on that well it's not that I don't even
agree it's that I'm not sure what you
mean so I want you to tell me a little
bit more about this sense in which this
is knowledge so I don't actually by
nagels or Jackson's original argument
about Mary the color scientist or what
it is like to be a bet etc you know I
think that there I think there are two
things there's the totality of the
physical world
and then the second thing is the many
many many ways that we talk about what's
going on in the fist night work right
yeah and experience the physical world
so so the word knowledge I mean you were
commenting earlier that that a lot of
words that we use in our vocabulary or
freighted and ambiguous and perhaps
knowledge is one of those words when
probably every single word that we're
using right now in our sentence is
affrighted weighted I remember that that
curt girdle who was a member of the
vienna circle in the 1930s came to the
point of view that he didn't understand
how anybody understood what anybody else
was saying at any time because of the
ambiguity of every single word in a
sentence so i would rather use a word
like experience right the knowledge was
also as fuzzy because knowledge seems to
me to have more to be more freight it
even than experience or feeling there's
there's an experience a set of
experiences or a set of feelings i
believe that do not lend themselves to
analysis by science and that is it right
now with what we know right now that
doesn't mean at some point in the future
we make we may not be able to do a
better job at this but i would say that
right now that do not lend themselves to
to analysis by science and so the
question is if you agree and you may
only partly agree that there are such
experiences what should be our attitude
towards them we are a scientific and
technological society but we also have
the arts and we have the humanities and
how do we place these other feelings and
experiences that are not analyzable by
science into the full context of being
human
and I think that we should honor them we
should recognize if their experiences
that we have and feelings to do not lie
within the scientific domain even though
they may be ultimately rooted in atoms
and molecules right so I would say you
know I think that I'm definitely
sympathetic to the idea but I do have
some issues with the vocabulary like I
know that there are some scientists and
philosophers for that matter
who really actively think that the
humanities we would be better if they
were subsumed into the sciences and I
don't think that is true as sort of just
a strategic fact about how to understand
the world if I were to make a sales
pitch to those people I would say
something like look biology ultimately
depends on the standard model of
particle physics right you don't think
in biology it involves laws of nature
that that contradict our best
understanding of quantum field theory
etc but we all agree that the best way
to do biology is not to start with the
standard model of particle physics I
mean come on
and I think that one can make a very
similar case for the humanities and I
mean I don't quite want to sign on to
the language of not analyzable by
science because that does sound a little
more definitive and and metaphysical
that I want it to be I want to say that
the best way that we have of
understanding certain means of learning
certain things of gaining certain forms
of wisdom is more like reading books and
falling in love and listening to music
rather than by collecting data and
fitting curves yes I would agree with
that
and when I say not analyzable not
analyzable by the methods of science I
mean at the current time yeah I mean it
could be to go back to your particle
physics biology metaphor it could be
that at some point in the future we have
know all of the laws of particles and
forces and physics and we have to some
master computer and we can just plug in
or input a particular biological
situation
and the computer will spit out the
answer by going all the way down to the
bottom of particles and forces that that
could happen in principle but even then
even if that could happen I think that
you know that I would take on the other
side you know the the it wouldn't be the
best tool it was cool exactly you know I
think the Daniel Dennett makes this
point very very well that you know
there's there is a simple computational
algorithmic improvement when you
understand things at a higher level you
can get more out for less than if you
just did the brute forcing of the lower
level micro physics and I think yeah
this is an important part of how the
world works that that is that could have
been otherwise right I mean we might
have been in a world where in order to
understand anything you need to
understand what every atom and molecule
and that thing was doing right happily
we're not in such a world there are
other vocabularies we can use that give
us enormous understanding of what's
going on yeah and also it depends on on
what you mean by the word understand
also true yes very very much but good so
I think that you know we're quite close
on this issue and the other one that I
wanted to one of the other ones I have
other things that elevate better if we
weren't close I know you have a more
interesting conversation we'll get there
you also have said in the context of
conversations like this you said some
some words that get certain people's
ears perked up about faith and science
in the sense that even scientists need a
certain kind of faith and so let me let
you make the pitch for that and then I
think I'm gonna disagree with it but
yeah we'll see if we don't smooth it out
okay well what I mean by faith is belief
and something that we can't prove that's
what I mean by the word face so I'll
begin by defining that word and I
believe that that we scientists take it
as a working hypothesis that the world
is lawful yeah
yes I do too and that that the the laws
that we discover here on earth apply
elsewhere in the universe and we we take
that as a as a given and then go about
you know solving our equations are doing
our experiments and the reason why I
think that I consider that to be a
question of faith is because it's the
belief in something that we can't prove
we can't prove that the universe is
lawful a zillion light-years away we
can't prove that and we can't even prove
that the universe will be lawful
tomorrow we can't prove that there may
not be an experiment that we do tomorrow
that defies all of the laws that we
discovered of course it could be that
there's you know a new law that we just
haven't found out that explains that
phenomenon it's it's it's it's a
question of a matter of faith in the
belief of these things so in the way
that I use the word faith so I'm ready
for you to disagree and we'll get into
another discussion yeah so I think that
you know our disagreements are small I
disagree in two senses one is this is an
example where the word is to fray 'td by
other connotation mhm
I mean you you even sort of gave away
the game a little bit when you said when
you were explaining it you know we have
provisional hypotheses like if I say the
science has provisional hypotheses that
no one is going to disagree with you
right but the word faith does have
connotations that that sort of get in
the way and I think that and I think
there's a substantive difference because
I can imagine you know scientists have
this provisional hypothesis for example
that the laws of physics are the same
from day to day right like that and we
can we can not solve David Humes problem
of induction but we can make an
assumption that it's not a big problem
that you know things that the patterns
from the past are a good guide to the
future but I could imagine them changing
their minds about that
right or I could imagine you know
scientists think that their sense data
is a relatively accurate reflection of
what's happening in the world but I can
imagine them changing their minds about
that if new data came in I think that
it's not so much a matter of faiths as
it is prior probabilities in a Bayesian
sense which could easily be updated in a
way that most religious people who talk
about their faith probably would not
allow for I agree with you mostly but I
don't think that any scientist would
ever say that there's some part of the
universe that is intrinsically not
lawful
and when I say lawful I mean that Bayes
cause-and-effect relationships that that
obeys ultimately some equation that you
can solve that can be used to predict
the phenomenon I think that I don't know
well actually I do know a becomes ayat
if you don't believe that yeah I do know
of a couple of scientists who believe
that but um I would say that the
majority of scientists do not and would
not question the assumption that the
universe is a lawful place with
lawfulness just defining the way that
I've just done and you can say whether
that's I don't think that's provisional
I think that that's that's an uber
assumption it's not provisional in the
sense that Einstein's theory of general
relativity is prevent provisional
because we know that it doesn't include
quantum effects yeah and ultimately
there will be a quantum theory of
gravity which don't we just don't happen
to possess at the moment it's not
provisional in that sense it's it's it's
an underlying uber assumption that we
make when we do science that the
universe is a lawful place well let's
make it a little bit more specific let's
make it more concrete in down-to-earth
here do you think that the methods of
scientific investigation could in
principle in some world or another lead
scientists who believe that God exists
okay well you have to define what you
mean by God
yeah supernatural all-powerful
omnipotent being who created the
universe and cares about the lives of
human beings here on earth
I think it's conceivable that that we
could prove that such a being exists yes
III I think that that if such a being
existed and made itself known in some
way and scientists did various tests I
think it's possible they would convince
themselves yes this is the real deal
I think that that's not impossible yeah
okay good so you know we're at the end
of the day I think that we're both
describing a way of understanding the
world that is sort of good Bayesian
slash empiricist right like of course we
have some background assumptions but I
you know I try to warn against ever
setting the credence we give to almost
any proposition to either 0 or 1
because that means that no amount of
information would ever change your mind
and I think most scientists don't do
that like what will say that something's
never gonna happen but what we really
mean is we just think it's really really
unlikely right right I totally agree
with you yeah okay so I think that you
know given our metaphysical and
ontological differences are rather small
and maybe maybe our differences are zero
anywhere but but there's a whole nother
set of issues that comes in here which
is the sort of more strategic questions
right like how should we engage publicly
and for that matter privately on issues
like this and you know I suspect that
part of your motivation you'll correct
me if I'm wrong for writing a book like
this is to push back a little bit on the
public efforts by some scientists and
others to be not just atheist but anti
religion you think that's going too far
is that fair I do think it's going
before
anti-religion yes yes I think that's
going too far
so how do you think that scientists
should talk to or talk about religious
belief in the public sphere wonderful
question
I think that the the physical world is
the domain of science and I think that
that any statements about the physical
world such as how many years ago the
earth was formed are in that in the
domain of science and I think that those
kinds of statements or questions must be
subjected to the kind of inquiry that we
do in science to scientific inquiry if
you have a belief in a world that lies
outside of the physical world then I
don't think that science has that much
to say about such a belief and an
example of that would be if you believed
in a Supreme Being who created the
universe but a being who does not suffer
pointedly enter the universe and
interfere with it or do what we we
commonly call miracles then that belief
to me is is compatible with science
because your supreme being is not
entering or interfering with the
physical world and I think that those
kinds of beliefs should be respected I
think that people who have religious
faith should be respected even people
who have a belief in an interview a God
that does intervene or secret
supernatural I think that you would you
would you could argue with them and say
well I think that that that that is
events are part of the physical world
and have to be subjected to the methods
of science but there are a lot of
intelligent people who have such beliefs
and I'm now I'm talking about belief in
an intervening God absolutely yet there
are a lot of intelligent people who have
such beliefs and I think that we
politely disagree with them when I say
we I mean people like you and me who
have very similar views we politely
disagree with them but we don't
condescend to them we we respected their
beliefs I mean I can respect a person's
belief that I don't agree with I can
respect them as a person and what has
disturb disturb and upset me about the
group of scientists in recent years who
have used scientific arguments to try to
disprove the existence of God that this
group of people that we sometimes call
the Neo atheists what bothers me about
them is any statements that appear to be
dismissive or condescending to believers
well just to be very clear you know this
will come up I'm sure the idea of
respect is is an important one in a
crucial one and it's worth getting it
right because you sort of gone back and
forth between saying we should respect
certain beliefs and we should respect
the people who have them and I know some
people are gonna say well wait a minute
I can respect the person who has them
but I don't do them any favors by
anything other than ridiculing their
belief if I think it's it's nonsense
well I'm not I I said that I think you
can disagree with them I mean they're
they're Republicans and Democrats who
disagree on the role of the of the
federal government and and managing
things at the state level and those are
you know they're there they're valid
intellectual discussions and it's
probably issues that will never
be solved and the ongoing conversation
is healthy
certainly we should expect the people
who have those beliefs in unless they
have some kind of misbehavior that other
kinds of misbehavior that lose our
respect but on the belief itself I think
that we're all entitled to believe what
we believe and to defend it by what
other arguments we have people who
believe in a God that intervenes in the
physical world and performs miracles I
just don't believe that and and I will
argue against that using all of the
knowledge of science that I have but in
the end I'm not going to say that that
person is a fool
or is a non thinker sure but it can is
there are there some beliefs that don't
deserve respect I mean is there is there
what do we do with people who are
steady-state errs or homeopathy or
anti-vaxxers or astrology buffs like do
those yeah of course I would still like
to respect them people if they're
respectful if they're good people and
writers write or whatever but yeah or is
that a different category that well
leaving in an interventionist God well I
think that there that's similar I mean
people who if someone had came and told
me that did they believe that that every
night while I'm asleep that that the
moon turns purple yeah and then it turns
white again when I wake up I would just
say you know let's do an experiment and
test that view so that's my attitude
towards people who have beliefs about
the physical world that I consider
nonsensical I would say let's let's do
the experiment and find out and I think
that that some years ago Richard Fineman
did something very similar to this with
with magicians
there were magicians who claimed that
they they had ESP or I can't remember
what are the worst or when you you have
telekinesis maybe
Kinesis yes telekinesis I think this was
in the in the 1960s and he actually had
serious conversations with such people
and said let's let's test this
scientifically and I think that he
actually had an open mind I mean I'm
sure that he had an opinion about the
way it was going to turn out but he
actually did experiments with such
people and that I thought was a very
respectful way to approach such people
and their beliefs so I mean at the end
of the day how much of this just comes
down to one's personality right I think
that some people just kind of take joy
in being a little feisty err to be
polite about it right me more combative
and then people on both sides right yeah
yeah no I agree with you I think it's
partly a matter of personality yeah I
totally agree
I mean how and there I know in politics
this is certainly true and probably and
talk about religion is also true there's
this tendency we all have to have a
favourite way of doing things and then
to believe that that favorite way of
doing things is also operationally the
best all right you know like if you are
leftist you say like no being far
leftist will actually get us more votes
and if you're centrist you know be more
centrist or being farm light or whatever
so how do we know you know as a if we
say there are certain things that we all
want to be true we want the people to be
rational and evidence-based and believe
in science how do we know whether we
attain those goals by being you know
having the strategy of talking in more
respectful ways about their beliefs
versus just coming out and saying no
that's come on that's just nonsense well
that's a great question and I don't know
the answer to that and I suspect that
the optimum strategy would vary from one
individual to the next that is I think
there some people
that you and I might consider have crazy
beliefs crazy in our opinion that that
would be susceptible to leading them
through a rational argument and I
suspect there are other people who have
the same crazy beliefs but just
different people who would not be
receptive to leading them through
rational arguments so I really think
that it you know it depends on your zip
code your local zip code yeah you're
really local zip code and I think that
it's not a situation where one size fits
all I think that in dealing with people
who think that climate change is a hoax
for example that we can't lump them all
into one category that we need to find
out more about those people and and why
they have their beliefs and tailor our
our argument or our dialogue with them
to to the people or another strategy
might be to to put out all different
strategies and hope that the the people
will be that the individual people with
their own zip codes will be swayed by
the particular strategy that appeals to
them yeah I think that I can make
arguments of both sides of this one you
know personally yeah and I have I think
that on the one hand a really full
throated insistence that God does not
exist and we should be more scientific
and so forth like we get from Richard
Dawkins most famously and has had a very
salutary effect on the public discussion
I think that twenty years ago it was
considered less respectable to be
atheist in public than it is today and
so I think that's had a good effect on
the other hand it's had a bad effect in
the sense that there's a community of
people who really just enjoy patting
themselves on the back for being more
rational than their fellow human beings
right in a way that is maybe not
productive and more about sport
point-scoring than about making the
world a better place yes well I think
that Richard Dawkins could have had
pretty much the same impact that he had
the salutary impact that you're
referring to without having the that the
ridiculing dismissive condescending
attitude towards believers that he's had
I don't think that that was a necessary
ingredients of the cake it's possible
part of me wonders whether or not that's
like telling someone if they tell you a
story about how they went to Vegas and
they were playing blackjack and they
were up $50,000 and they lost it all and
you say well you should have quit after
you'd won $50,000 and I feel like saying
well but the kind of person who would
quit after they won $50,000 would never
have won $50,000 in the first place oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a good point
yeah it's possible that you could not
recreate Richard Dawkins and a version
that did not include that aspect that I
ridiculing and the condescending and so
on so so that's a fair point so I can't
argue with you there and I think that
the more you know the sort of
forward-looking question is how do we
fit in the real implications or
potential implications of religious
belief on to how we act in society and
coming from essentially atheist
scientific perspective I remember once I
was had a one of these sort of
gatherings of many people from many
different disciplines and so forth and I
was put on a panel to discuss the
relationship between religious belief
and public policy and it was like 10
people on the panel and I was the only
atheist and I was really there as like a
little entertainment world right yeah
yeah and and indeed the only question I
was asked was what is the best argument
you have for religious belief even
though you don't have it yourself yeah
and I think that does eat we're not
there yet in terms of not just I think
the atheist said now have a seat at the
table in a way they didn't before but
they don't have a lot of
they don't have a lot of juice when it
comes to really saying look you know as
a naturalist who thinks that you know
the laws of morality are not handed down
by God
here is the implications that I draw for
how we actually live here in the world
mm-hmm
do you have thoughts about how we can be
better well the first thought is just
that not to ridicule believers that's
thought number one yeah to respect their
intelligence because there are many many
believers who are quite intelligent
people I think that we can talk about
morality which is one of the aspects of
religion without invoking God or
supernatural events I think that we
don't need God to give us a code from
for moral behavior
the the golden rule do unto others as
you would have them do unto you which to
me has always been the supreme guide for
moral behavior is found in all religions
is also found in Buddhism which doesn't
even believe in a Supreme Being yeah so
I think that there are ways that we can
talk about ethical and moral behavior
that don't involve a supernatural the
supernatural realm and so that that's I
don't know whether I could say a lot
more than that well you know I certainly
agree with you there I guess my question
is more given that where can we get some
of the moral authority that our society
tends to get a lot of Jemaine priest
yeah you know based people yeah well I
think that we that that we it's a great
question I think that you can get some
moral authority by referring to
non-believers
who are unquestionably very moral
ethical humanitarian people and just as
we you know sometimes refer to people
like Mahatma Gandhi as being a spiritual
leader who provides us with some kind of
moral compass I believe that there are
atheists in the world they may not be
card-carrying burn the house down
atheists but but quiet atheists and I
think you're probably a quiet atheist
who by their own behavior demonstrate
principles of morality and human
humanitarian behavior and caring for
other human beings so that's the best
way that I know of accumulating moral
authority outside of the standard
religious platform yeah I do think that
the idea of just being a good example is
underrated when it comes to you know
trying to yes I mean to influence things
like we're trained to have rational
arguments but rational arguments as an
actual strategy to change the world take
you so far but it doesn't think right as
far as you might want to go yes so to
wrap up I think you know the last thing
I want to ask you we talk about morality
and in sort of a naturalistic context
but coming back to your book there's
also the question of meaningfulness in a
natural miss Lincoln I mean wonderful
question yeah there's a lot of people
who are gonna say like I'm not I don't
care about the argument from design or
the fine-tuning arguments or the
ontological are going through the
existence of God what I care about is
the fact that it gives my life purpose
to believe that there's a bigger thing
out that there's a reason why I exist do
you think life is a relationship between
this kind of transcendent experience
that you focused on in the book and how
secular people can find meaning and
purpose in their own lives well it's
interesting that you ask this because a
couple of nights ago
I was at a an event at MIT sponsor Bob
the organization called Veritas oh yeah
uh ahem - you've done that - and there
was a philosopher from Notre Dame Meghan
I can't remember her last name and she
we were talking about meaning and she
argued that that that a meaningful life
is found by doing things that that are
valued by God and since God provides
permanence and eternity that we are
connecting our values with things that
are permanent by sort of fastening
ourselves onto God and during the the
the next part of the the conversation
between me and her was and on such
conversation I asked her well suppose
you're an agnostic or an atheist then
are you out of luck and I think that the
the the assumption here is that meaning
that the assumption that I want a
question is whether meaning requires
permanence hmm do you have to have some
scaffolding that is permanent or eternal
which of course God provides if you are
to find meaning and if you if you if you
don't believe in God as you and I don't
that that scaffolding of permanence
doesn't exist and even as you know very
well our entire universe will well and
or go into emptiness at some point in
the future so there's really nothing
that's permanent in the physical
universe and if there if God doesn't
exist then what is there and I think
that and I've worried about this a lot
myself and the conclusion I've come to
is that you are making a fallacy
when you start off with the assumption
that meaning requires permanence and
I've come around to the point of view
which is very hard to do but I believe
in that you have to find meaning in the
present moment this also as a Buddhist
view although the Buddhists do have
their Nirvana which is permanent but
just enjoy and and be open to every
moment and experience every moment for
what it is and I think that that's where
meaning lies for me ya know I am
completely on board with that there's a
reason why in my last book the big
picture where I talk about these things
a little bit
I emphasize the fact that we're all
gonna die I have a chapter called three
million heartbeats cuz that's the
average number of heartbeats in the
human lifespan and and I think it's a
crucial thing I think that you know as
much as atheism or naturalism has
increased in popularity and acceptance
over the past few decades there's a lot
still remaining for a theist and
naturalist to do in getting their
worldview all together right and part of
that is that the most atheist and
naturalistic among them still implicitly
cling to some standards that have been
handed down by religious belief I think
you've gotten pointed one about the
permanence right like if something is
right permanent yes yes I think the same
thing for morality there's a lot of
people here who think that unless you
have rock-solid absolutely objective
moral guidelines nothing and I think
that the the sort of secret implication
of naturalism and atheism and science is
that you know you have to buy into
temporariness and fuzziness and
contingency and perspective and some
things are just not there
absolutely and permanently and that's
okay yes I totally agree with you and
are there so I guess the very final
question is this is not a small class
but are there programmatic things that
naturalist can do to find or improve
their you know
hold on meaning and and and
meaningfulness in the world or their you
know is it meditation is it going to
music is it having an island main
retreat or you know what can we all do
so this is something that you can do for
for you're just yourself this is a
personal activity for your personal
meaning let's say short let's say we're
not talking about trying to write
impactful books to affect hundreds of
thousands of other people we're talking
about what can you do in your own life
to give meaning to your own life if you
are let's say an atheists or atheist or
a secularists well you know as part of
my sort of meaning pluralism I think
that some people will very naturally be
inward looking when it comes to meaning
and some people will be very naturally I
went looking and I think either one is
okay if that's where they find it Yeah
right well I think that the first thing
to do is is the recognition that there's
no cosmic meaning that you're not going
to find meaning and the the recipe for
to lead a meaningful life written on
some tablets out there in outer space
yeah and and it's important to recognize
that that's a very important first step
and and every person has to find meaning
for themselves and what is meaningful to
you may not be meaningful to someone
else and it might be very meaningful to
you to go out and have a quiet dinner
with friends and a nice glass of wine
and talk and for someone else that might
be a total waste of time to boredom yes
right worse worse than a waste of time
yeah but that other person might find
something very meaningful
sitting at home listening to a Bach
fugue and I think that you know I know
that as I think Aristotle wrote about
happiness and said that you never know
when you're when you're happiest and
when it's happening it's always in
retrospect that you don't know at the
moment and it may be that meaning is is
like that that you you you you you try
to do experiences that that you feel are
worthwhile and then make you feel good
and it may be that it's only later in
retrospect that you say that was a
meaningful experience yeah I do I do
tend to wonder whether or not those of
us who feel moved to talk about meaning
in some careful way might not tend to
put to prejudice Bach fugues over going
to baseball games I think that you know
you probably need to do a better job of
bringing meaning to a more Universal
level but I've but we agree I think that
it's it's personal and you can different
people gonna find in different ways and
that is not a flaw in the system that's
right that's not a flaw in the system
and and that's that's a key insight into
this discussion oppelo yeah absolutely
all right this has been very helpful
very meaningful hopefully people will
find some some transcendent experiences
in the last hour so al limón thanks so
much for being on the podcast Thank You
Sean great to be with you
[Music]
you
[Music]